Thank you for coming.
We have a really important topic
here today for the talks at Google.
It's my pleasure to be able to introduce
and mc the next hour with Kyra Kyle's.
She's here to talk to us
about a very important topic.
One of my colleagues actually heard
her speak at a conference and we felt
compelled to really help
broadcast the message,
diversify or die,
why news media need to
reflect their audience.
What we'll do is we'll hear
from Cara, speak for, uh,
go through the presentation.
We'll have a discussion,
I'll ask a few questions.
We have some open mics
for a lively Q and a.
To tell you a little bit about Kira is,
she is the co founder of
Mith lab entertainment.
She founded this company with her sister.
It's a multicultural agency,
multi-platform.
She's also the former editor
and chief of Ebony magazine.
So without further ado,
please welcome Kara Kyle's
okay.
Yeah.
Good morning everyone. How
are you? Good. Wonderful.
So thank you so much for the
warm introduction and it's
really great to be here.
I really appreciate people coming out
to talk about a topic that is extremely
important to me. Um, as
Natalie mentioned, you,
I've been in the journalism industry
for about 20 years and it's interesting
that the industry has
changed in so many ways,
especially as it pertains to
technology and the advertising models.
But there's one area where I feel that
it's woefully behind and that's why I'm
here with the dawning title to diversify
or die because sometimes you have to
scare people in order to
make them make a change.
So we're going to go with
the minority report now.
So just to give you a little
bit more detail about me,
I did work at Ebony magazine where I
was the editor and chief and also the
senior vice president
of digital editorial.
And honestly that is the first black
owned company that I worked for.
And Ebony is an interesting story because
this is a 70 plus year old company.
And the reason it was started is because
even back then of course there was a
dearth of positive news or affirming
news or even just factual news about
African Americans.
And it's,
it's sad to me in a way that
something like that is needed.
I mean we obviously love it and we're
excited about that and other black owned
and black run media entities. But
the fact is this problem, you know,
has his predates most of
us and it still continues.
So I also have had the benefit of working
with a lot of mainstream outlets and
that's what gives me some perspective
in terms of, I came from Tribune,
I worked with the Sun Times,
I've worked with vibe.com
work with a number of dailies.
And even in college it was already
obvious to me that there was a majority of
white males to be honest at, at
these places. And because of that,
there was a certain perspective.
None of this I think is malicious.
I don't think it's done to x anyone out.
But there were just certain
factors that are affecting us.
And I think we have to be cognizant
about it, not only as participants,
like someone like me, but
our audience. You know,
someone like you and that you're
empowered here at Google to be able to do
something about it because you're such a
huge factor, uh, with the media industry.
So I'll tell you a little personal story
about how I figured out really that I
could never, never, never
leave the journalism industry
because, I don't know, I,
it was like,
there are so few of us,
we feel compelled to remain within it
even though it can be very brutal in
punishing at times. You know,
we were losing ad revenue,
we're losing people many times. But
there, this is one of the reasons why.
So Hurricane Katrina,
um,
I was in the newsroom at the time and I
was one of a handful of African American
journalists where I worked most of
the black people to be quite frank,
that worked there were, um, in the
secretarial pool, administrative security.
There were not very
many black journalists.
So one day I was called down to
the big board room, you know,
and I was kind of intimidated because
I'm thinking typically, you know,
the big editors don't call down like
an editor or a reporter at the time.
I was a column is what on Earth did I do?
So I'm thinking,
did I write something wrong in a story?
You know,
was there like a bunch of people with
pitchforks waiting for me outside of like
what happened that they're
calling me into this room?
And what happened is it was
hurricane Katrina had hit a,
everybody was scrambling to do coverage.
And so these editors called me down to
this big board room with these, you know,
all these books and leather
bound books and couches.
And what they wanted to ask me is if
I thought it was okay if they refer to
those effected by Hurricane Katrina
as refugees. So it was like,
okay. Um hmm. First of all,
let me tell you that I cannot exonerate
you no matter what you do. I, you know,
I like to think of myself as very regal,
but I'm not the queen of blackness.
There's nothing, you know,
no one I can wave and say,
this is what you should do
and you won't get in trouble.
But I will answer your
question with a question.
If something happened in Iowa
or Idaho or here in Chicago,
would you refer to the people affected as
refugees? And they immediately said no.
So I think I'm glad they asked. I'm not
grateful that they asked. They should ask,
but I'm glad that they asked and that
I was there to talk to them about this
because it could have
been a very big misstep.
But I think that that's what brings us
here today is that because there were so
few people there up in those top
higher echelons, they honestly,
we're going to go with that. Had I not
said anything and they had an occurred,
it did occur to them to ask,
which is important.
But the fact is that they couldn't come
up with a consensus without asking me is
another issue.
So you might recognize this for him.
So media is definitely failing.
It's multicultural audiences
and this is dear white people,
which by the way is very good on Netflix
if you haven't seen the show. And um,
I don't think that this is a point
that the, we can go over too much.
I think people believe sometimes that
there's just like this small descending
minority people who want to see all
this positive news about multicultural
groups.
And I really don't think that's true.
I think people just want to see factual,
accurate reporting.
They want to see nuance.
They want to see stories that are not
just crime or stories that are not just
about race or politics.
They want to see stories that
reflect the American population.
So when I say that to people,
sometimes they think, well, you know,
there's been some progress,
but the fact of the matter is there
hasn't been enough progress compared
considering the American population,
which I'll go into.
So what I've done with the presentation
is I have put some factoids in here
because I think, you know, when you,
when you're telling personal stories,
people kind of get it. But I think if you
see numbers than people totally get it.
So this one is don't sleep. And
for obvious reasons, you know,
we, I think we take a lot
of things for granted,
especially in America regarding our
population. But in just five years,
about 50.2% of children born in
the United States will be minority.
So the whole definition of
minority is changing. Uh,
in 2020 white children will be the
minority in the United States and this is
according to the census. And then
in 2016, this is really jarring.
62% of the population
that identifies as white,
we'll drop all the way down to about 44%.
So when you see these newsrooms and
things are changing in certain areas,
but when you go to a lot of traditional
newsrooms, what you will see is, you know,
white, older males and that does
not at all reflect the population.
So there are issues and things that are
lost in translation because of that.
So,
and I know this as well as anyone,
you would love to believe that maybe
media coverage will change because people
are just awesome and people are awesome,
but it's not just altruism that's
going to get us to this next area.
So I think it's important for people
to realize what the potential of this
market is. And so I'll just go over a
couple of the stats that I have here,
but for example, magazines. I
came from the magazine industry.
We all know that print magazines are
not doing very well just because the
advertising model has shifted so much,
but of the mainstream population,
which 55% are reading magazines,
minority populations read 65%.
So there's an overindex there.
In terms of radio,
you know,
everybody talks about the death
of radio when you've got podcasts.
We've got all these technologies
coming out. However,
minority communities are listening to
20 hours of radio a week compared to 10
hours for just the mainstream
population. Um, in terms of apps,
watching videos, which is another really
important area also for advertising's,
people are always slipping those little
videos in there. 56 hours a month.
That's what black, uh, citizen's
alone are watching on their apps,
their 81% more likely to
show support for a brand,
which is super important because we
always talk about brand influencers and
people that can tout your brand,
especially in a crowded marketplace.
And this is extremely important to note.
76% will share their opinions, you
know, on some of the social media.
So I think that's important to think
about because when things don't go right,
you know, it can, it can
be an ugly situation.
I'm sure we've all heard the term
black Twitter and we've all heard about
dragging and it is a real
thing. You know, I've,
I've only been kind of dragged
ones like just a light tug,
but I can promise you that I
don't want any more of that.
So I definitely advise
against being dragged. Um,
that another reason that African American
audience is important is that it's
becoming much a more educated community.
Um,
household income is increasing I think
because we see so many of these stories
and headlines that talk about
what isn't going right. You know,
the crime rates or um, issues with
black lives matters because of that.
There's a sort of almost like a blind
spot with the mainstream media when it
comes to this population.
And that is why I believe there are so
much like story ideation around these
negative developments.
And I do Miss President Obama,
sorry I had to say that I
know everyone's gone. So 75%,
I think this is horrible.
75% of African Americans distrust
of the media that they read.
So if you think about it,
and that's insulting to me actually as
somebody who went to school for this
worked hard on fact checking for me
to be writing something. And you know,
when I was maybe in more
of a mainstream outlet,
I don't think I experienced this as
much when I was at a black owned pub
publication.
For somebody to be giving me the side
eye to the rate of 75% that is extremely
high.
And I think that demonstrates that this
is not a problem that is just among a
small group of people.
This is widespread.
And I'll tell you why.
You know and I have some examples.
The funny thing is whenever
I talk about this topic,
it takes me two seconds
to find a new example.
I wish I could bring you an
example from 2016 and say, Oh,
this is back in the bad old days.
No,
I have a very fresh example for you so
I won't go through all of these cause I
really do want to get to talking to
everybody about this issue and what your
thoughts are on it.
But I'll just highlight a few.
The ones that make me the most physically
ill, we'll start with Ms Kardashians.
No shade to their cardiac and clan.
They are doing their thing. However,
Kim Kardashians,
by no means invented corn rows.
The fact that a magazine would put out
a story saying that she created this
trend called boxer braids,
which basically is the way my mother
used to braid my hair when I would swim
when I was like seven years old. I
was like, this is a slap. I mean,
did you do any research? Did you ask
anyone? Have you ever been anywhere?
Because that to me it was just so galling
and I think it really offends, um,
individuals. I have in the
audience here today, Wendy Wilson,
who was one of my colleagues from Ebony
and we talked about that in the fashion
industry in particular,
it seems like there is just this,
this blindness towards black women.
And this is an example of it.
Here's another one that made me irate
when I'm the New York Times referred to
Viola Davis is not classically beautiful
according to who did they not see her
at the Golden Globes when she was
serving with her yellow dress.
I mean it was just the, the
nerve of someone to come up
with something like that.
And when you say classically beautiful,
you understand what the implication is,
what does that mean? That she's not
blonde, that she's not, you know,
what are you saying when
you talk about that? No,
she does not necessarily look like
scarlet Johannson but is there not room in
the spectrum for her to be
considered beautiful as well? Um,
the Mike Brown situation,
uh, when in Ferguson,
when the news outlets and I, again,
I don't think this was purposeful.
I think it was because they
were racing against the clock.
You're trying to get new information,
but a lot of the stories showed the
image on the left if you can see it where
he's putting up his hand and I don't
necessarily think it is a gang symbol or
something, but there's some what of an
implication there. And then on the right,
you know,
you see him just living his life or you
could have used the graduation picture,
it could have used something else.
The bottom line is it,
a lot of media outlets hit back and said,
hey, we were under time crunch. We got,
this is the picture that we had.
We had to run with it. However,
I think it's obvious that in many cases
when there's a story about a white team,
even in a similar situation,
they will get a graduation picture,
a picture with family,
something that doesn't have any
sort of a negative connotation.
And people notice that.
And it actually started a trending topic
on if the aforementioned black Twitter
of what photo will they use when I
die, because any one of us, you know,
it's taken a picture that we might
not necessarily want to see again.
And to use that as the photo,
it does definitely sway public opinion.
And I can admit to you the
outlet that I was working with,
we were in the same position.
We did use that photo because honestly,
when I looked at it, I didn't see
it as being in any way nefarious.
But once the public said, hey
guys, this picture is bad,
please take this down or
find something else. We did.
The issue is when people say something
or when the public speaks out and then no
one, no one responds. And
then this is my fave. Oh boy.
So we recently had the revelation that,
um,
how to show natural hairstyles.
So I don't know if you could see
the picture on the bottom right.
They had a story about how to rock
natural hairstyles in pop sugar and every
single woman in this story was white.
Now I understand that all hair is natural
when it comes down to it, you know,
unless you're growing some kind
of acrylic out of your head,
everything is natural.
But black women have clearly taken this
term and we're using it for the purpose
that we have not traditionally been able
to wear our hair as it grows out of our
heads.
In a traditional workplace mean there's
still legislation that allows you to
fire someone if they have locks.
So we're not at a place where we can,
you know, all lives matter of hair, you
know. So when this publication did this,
the retribution was swift. But my question
was, why did you ever do this? You know,
if you had just had somebody around
somebody's diverse in your circle,
this never would have happened.
Some of these things are totally
avoidable and that's the issue.
And the last one I'll point out,
and this is because again,
I don't think this is malicious,
but extremely hurtful that cosmo
did a lineup of trends that were,
you know, dad like rip, goodbye, you
ugly trend. And then they had hello,
gorgeous and they were ushering in the
new beautiful trends and about 90% of the
goodbye ugly trend. We're black women
and models Joanne smalls like it.
It was terrible, but I don't think,
again, it was not done deliberately but,
and they apologize for it,
but the fact is no one looked
at this lineup and thought
this could be a problem.
You know that that is the problem. So
again, sad that the examples continue.
So what are we looking for? You
know, Naomi's clapping it up for us.
We are looking for fair representation.
No one is looking for to be
treated better than anyone.
Just like you don't want to
be treated worse than anyone.
What we're looking for is even
simple issues. Stock Art. I,
and I had this happen, I will
not name the agency, but one day,
just out of curiosity,
I decided to do a search in this popular
stock art agencies collection and I put
in the word ghetto.
If I didn't get back,
every black person known to
man that was in their catalog,
I could not believe it. I mean
in this happened in 2016, um,
most of the images are
of people of non color.
It's very hard to find any sort
of minority in the stock art.
So I think the issue is that, and it's
being remedied, um, within the community.
I know several women,
for example,
who started agencies where they take
pictures and they make it available to the
media is used so that there are these,
these different images out there.
But the sad fact is that
in these major agencies,
there's only a very tiny and microscopic
selection you have to choose from.
And that's why if you look,
you'll notice that you kind of see the
same feature images and a lot of stories.
And that is why, because there just are
not a lot of images of people of color,
period, not just African Americans. Um,
I think asking people to be part
of stories that are not about race,
that are not about class,
that are not about politics.
Asking people questions about riding
bikes. You know, I ride bikes somewhat,
you know, not very well.
But I do, you know, I,
I would like to be interviewed for stories
that don't necessarily base upon the
way that I look. You know, as a
person, like we're all humans,
we're all Americans and we're
all peak global citizens.
Why shouldn't we be included
in other stories? Um,
being authentic and showing people,
you know, just because it's cool,
you know, for example, um,
I think sometimes like people fixate on
a certain pop culture citizen, like, uh,
you know, this is an unpopular topic
right now, but a black China for example,
or something like that, and the people
just discovered who this is. It's like,
come on now,
you know,
and they go all in and they give them
covers and they give them this and it just
rings false because it's obvious that
you're not interested in anyone else.
You're just interested in specific black
people that are undeniably popular at
the moment.
And otherwise,
this wouldn't be something that
you would work very hard at.
So that can be a huge problem.
Um,
I think even what I learned when I was
in school that the professors always told
us, um, interviewing a lawyer,
interviewing a professor, make an effort,
especially if it's not a story based
around race to talk to people of different
areas of the spectrum because
you want to mirror the populace.
And I think that unfortunately because
people are in a rush and they have these
circles of people that they talk to,
they just want to continue in that vein.
But I think we just really have to
ask ourselves to expand and there are
publications that are doing a much better
job because I don't like to keep it
all negative. You know, I want to
talk about some good success stories.
Washington Post has been doing an
incredible job. I'm Huffington Post,
black voices does a great
job with a small staff.
They're able to cover a lot of issues.
They have a lot of op eds,
but they also do really good
investigative reporting. There's,
they stress the importance of covering
black community across the diaspora.
Buzzfeed is doing a really good job and
what I really want to commend them for
is transparency. What
what I've run into, um,
as a member of the National Association
of black journalists is that news
outlets don't want to tell you who
they have there. They like we're,
we're a group of people that
are always asking questions,
but this is a question that
we don't want to answer.
So you don't know what the proportions
are. Even when they do surveys,
there's a low return of,
of, of organizations that
will provide background.
So buzzfeed did that, you know, they
talk about how many people they have,
they talk about black and they talk
about Asian, they talk about women,
they let people know what they're doing.
And yes,
you open yourself up to criticism.
Someone could look at that and say,
well that's not enough.
But the bottom line is I think that if
you open yourself up to that criticism,
it shows that you are willing to fix it.
And when you hide it,
it makes it seem like you want
to keep things in the status quo.
And I think another important
question for us to ask, you know,
I know that as I said,
Google is extremely important,
but even just as individuals
we can do things, you know,
something that I just did recently and I
was just using my own example because I
don't want to put anyone else out
there on front street necessarily,
but a friend of a friend of a friend of
mine went into a seven 11 in Chicago.
She, she, she was a mother. She sent
her two boys that were teenagers,
like very young boys into the store
to pick up food for their lunch.
And within minutes they were
back outside with nothing.
And she asked him what happened and the
little boys, they just said, you know,
it's no problem. He just didn't want us
in there cause we're black. It's okay.
And she's like, wait a
minute, what that is not okay.
She took them back in the store.
She asked the clerk what he did and I
think he told on himself because he,
when asked about it, what he say, he said
something to her to the effect of, well,
I'm an American. Like
what do you, what is this?
An immigration office as a
seven 11 you know what I mean?
Like what does living in America
have to do with anything?
But that little video of her encountering
this man and really confronting him
about what he did to her sons.
I posted it.
I encourage a lot of other people to
post it. News outlets got into it.
And from what I understand,
he was removed from that store.
So there are things that we as individuals
can do with the power of smartphones,
with the power of social media.
If we see things that we don't like,
there's something that we can
do in response. Back in the day,
there was the letter to the editor that
could take months to surface and you
know, the reaction would be
equally slow, very glacial.
But now I think there's an immediate
reaction and you don't want to the gun.
Everything is not a racial situation.
But I think it is extremely important
that we take our voices and that we
channel those into positive change.
Because the bottom line is that as I said,
the demographic is changing, the country
is changing, the globe is changing.
And the last thing we want to do is
have the media that's supposed to be a
catalyst for revolution.
You know,
be the one that's kind of putting
down the revolution. So that's,
that's pretty much everything
that I wanted to, to say to you.
And I'd love to hear what you
have to say to me about the topic.
I know it can be hot button and sometimes
people can be a little fearful about
bringing up the, the, the issues.
But I think that's the only way
that we'll ever come to a solution.
So thank you so much for your attention.
I appreciate
[inaudible].
Thank you so much, Kyra. This is,
you have a powerful voice in such
a strong message and you know,
it is a tough topic. But with, with
staggering statistics like this,
we have to bring change and it doesn't
come quick. It doesn't come easy.
It's been a long time coming.
But um,
by having this conversation here today
and the impact that you've had in the
industry, um, it's a start and there
are ways that we can also take action.
I'd like to just start learning a
little bit more about you. You just,
how did you get an industry
had an accelerated master's
program at Northwestern,
dove right into journalism,
right? What sparked that interest?
No, I've always been interested in
writing ever since I was a little kid.
I often tell the story that my mom used
to occupy my time when I was a child by
putting me in front of a dressing room
mirror and I would sit there and do these
little broadcast so she
could shop, shop, shop,
and I would be doing the weather
and talking about the news.
I even had a Barbie magazine with my
sister that we forced my poor father to
read. He'd come home from work exhausted
and have this terrible magazine,
you know,
printed out and ready for him to read.
So it's funny because oftentimes people
say they want to be something when
they're little and then that
doesn't materialize. So in my case,
that is exactly what happened.
Amazing. And you, you, you
veered into the print media,
you also, you're heavily
involved in multi-platform. Um,
and you've kind of dabbled in each form,
if you will, on this topic of diversity.
And in the topic of media,
are there some sub verticals that
are doing it better than others,
whether it's broadcast, prime
time, newspapers, digital?
I would
they just by design,
because digital typically is,
it's a younger workforce.
It's, um, more malleable.
There aren't these entrenched employees
and entrenched ways of doing things.
Digital seems to be leading the way.
For example,
I believe it's about double the number
of women working for some of these online
outlets compared to your
traditional dailies.
So they are far and
beyond leading the way.
And I think they've actually worked
collectively to bring up the statistics of
the number of minorities in media when
added with these traditional outlets.
TV, I believe is among the
slowest, if I'm not mistaken,
and I, and that's probably
because it's a visual medium,
like we still have situations.
I don't know if,
if most of you saw the story about
the woman who does the weather,
who she got all these nasty viewer notes
because she was wearing her natural
hair on air.
And I mean the things that people said
you would have thought we'd climb into a
time machine and gone back,
you know,
the 1950s or sixties because
it's a visual medium,
it may be harder to adjust and to embrace
those trends. And viewers are older,
so they're used to seeing certain things.
So if they wake up and they see someone
that doesn't look like what they're used
to, they'll turn it off. And because
it's such a delicate situation,
they need that advertising model.
They still continue to follow
the audience in that way.
So I think unless you had a lot of young
people tuning in and voicing concerns
about what they're seeing,
that one is one that will
continue to be kind of stagnant.
And also behind the scenes
is extremely important.
A lot of people see people on the front
lines, they don't see the directors,
the producers, the writers
behind the scenes on TV. That
is also not very diverse.
And in newspapers you can kind of
tell a little bit more. But again,
you don't necessarily know the background
of, of people that you're reading.
But just statistically speaking,
as I understand it,
it's about 17% of the total news workforce
of those who responded are minorities
at this moment.
People of color.
So how with with such low numbers,
how can we bring change? Does
it, it counts just being, um,
I'll share a little bit about
the Google practices because we,
it's not just at the hiring stage,
it's also in the inclusion.
Diversity and inclusion is something
that's one of our pillars and values at
this company. Work to be done. And,
and that's because also in working
on the pipeline of applicants,
so there's another pillar that's
really critical to Google,
which is an education inspiring the next
generation and thinking about computer
science.
And the last pillar is our community.
How do we make sure that we bring
access to everyone, training SMB,
small and medium size businesses or others
so that they have the tools to grow,
um,
where,
how do we start bringing more diverse
voices into the world of journalism?
Is it in the schools? Is it h how would
you think about that approach? Yeah,
I definitely,
yeah,
I think education is a
critical piece because you,
you do need that training in order to
go into journalism though nowadays,
some of these sites you
might question that. But, um,
I think one really important thing is
that it's still kind of a privilege to
work in journalism.
People expect you to work for free.
Some people can't afford to do that,
especially somebody, a person of color,
maybe somebody who hasn't
inherited familial wealth.
They can't afford to do a free internship.
I've had situations when I was working
with ebony where someone was working in
retail and also coming in,
but they didn't have enough hours to
really make a significant difference.
I think that paying interns a decent
amount would help because that would give
them impetus to join the field and to be
trained the right way and also to then
get advocates from within the industry
that can reach back and say, Hey,
I had this really great intern. Here's
the role that this person could fill. Um,
people always hire from
within their circle. I think
that's across the industry.
And if you don't know people,
you cannot hire them if you've never
met them because they've had to work a
regular job because they can't afford
to work for free. You know, it's a,
it's a moot point to talk about diversity
if you're not doing those things.
And that goes across the board.
Even in Hollywood,
you people can't afford to work for
free for agents and that kind of thing.
And that's the reason why you see some
of the white washing that people talk
about in the movies.
I think also it's the audience.
I think the audience has to demand better.
I think they have to call
people on the carpet.
I recently saw I horrible industry article
was a review of the movie girls trip.
It,
I don't know what happened here.
It was just really
pointed and really biased.
And instead of evaluating it
like you would bridesmaids,
this author decided to compare this movie
that has nothing to do with anything
to um,
Tyler Perry's movies.
And I think it was because that was
his frame of reference, you know,
and that that would be like comparing
the Coen brothers to Seth macfarlane.
It doesn't make sense. Right. So, um,
you know, I think it is about exposure.
It's about audience driving
change and it is about, you know,
supporting journalists of color when you
see them and they're doing great work,
support them on social
media, follow them, you know,
get more familiar with their work so
that they can be touted. You know,
we've had several journalists who have
gotten the kind of treatment and it
really helps, um, you know,
and, and I think we just have
to continue in that vein.
It's,
it's not one bullet solution.
It's like a comprehensive change
that we're going to have to see.
Beautiful. You mentioned, I mean that the,
the need to have stronger and
more inclusive journalism voices.
I think there was a stat on your side
about 75% of African Americans actually
trust the source of news that they
don't write, don't trust. Right.
What happens is they're just,
um,
no more readership or do they turn
to different sources? What, I mean,
I think the people,
I think people continue to read
because this is the information,
but I think they take it with a huge
grain of salt. They think, okay,
the police are always right
in these stories that I read.
The person that's killed or hurt
or put in jail is always wrong. Um,
I think that there has also
been a proliferation of
blogs and different sites,
you know, and I would say for example,
like very smart brothers, the route,
you know,
they're in different areas,
some of our entertainment shadow and act
that have come to fill in these gaps.
And I think they're very successful,
but because they don't,
they still aren't the juggernauts and
some of these other sites are, you know,
bt has a huge audience. And so there are
news really infiltrates, but you know,
some of these smaller sites may be
aggregated, they have influenced,
but they're still not going to have the,
the half of say, the Tribune company,
which has all these different
affiliates. So, um, I,
I do believe it's
bringing forth new voices,
but I still think bringing
forward new voices is effective.
But it would be even more effective if
we could get some of those voices into
the traditional outlets
that people read the most.
And some of those people that read the
traditional outlets are the main ones
that need to read the new voices because
they're just kind of indoctrinated in
what they're accustomed to. And
sometimes that's very biased information.
It's uh, it's true. If we look at another
industry, the, the movies industry,
what happened with the Oscars last year,
it was pretty blatant terms of the lack
of diversity and one approach they took.
And I don't know if it's the right
one for other industries to look at,
but they said a number in terms of how
they wanted to elevate the number by 2020,
I think it was right, of women and
African American and Latino Writers.
What's your perspective on that?
I think that's a good step. Uh, I, again,
I do think it also has to
be within the rank and file.
It has to be the producers. It has to
be the script writers. It has to be,
there have to be more people
behind the scenes, the directors,
the cinematographers in order to really
make sure that we're seeing movies that
reflect the audience that's
sitting in front of it. I mean,
I'll say I've been reading recently
and I am a huge game of Thrones fan.
I once woke up with a person cause they
kept talking around the scenes. I'm like,
no, you're going to be quiet
or if we're done here. Um,
but I mean it is weird that in this
fantasy world where there are dragons and
white walkers and Zombie horses,
you can envision maybe three,
four people of color period.
And as weird to people,
I think you're coming into a time where
people are not willing to accept that.
And then on the reverse we have the Black
Panther trailers came out and people
lost their mind.
What is happening here?
Why wasn't there a role set aside for
Matt Damon? I'm not going to go see this.
And it's like,
listen,
Matt Damon had his term when he was
on the Great Wall of China for reasons
unknown. You know, we're going
to, we're going to let that go.
We're going to let Matt Damon take
a bench on this one. But um, I,
I think that you,
it's got to come from everywhere.
Having the judges have more diversity,
which is what they did is great,
but if there aren't more movies,
it's still not going to solve anything.
We need more movies out with people of
color behind as well as in front of the
scenes.
We do have good visibility in front of
the camera and that's getting better,
especially on TV. I think
television is really doing a
great job, but um, you know,
the industries are old and they show,
they're showing their age and I think
we're now starting to come up against a
generation that's not willing to just
accept that they're going to say, hey,
if you don't make it,
we'll go make it ourselves.
That's why you saw the
success of get out that movie.
I don't think it could have been
made like five or six years ago.
And now because of the
response it's getting,
you'll see more provocative
films like that, you know,
everything is not, you know,
I respect the Tyler Perry because
he's doing amazing things,
but everything is not Tyler Perry
and nor should it have to be.
And that shouldn't be the framework
by which movies with a black or black
executives is judged.
So though like it's a shared
responsibility from corporations to
also the talent producing the movies.
And he was a, a colleague of mine who
pointed out that Disney's Milan movie, um,
they were about to cast a,
a white male to be the of
the love interest and uh,
it was a petition of 90,000 folks,
which she signed it to,
to make a stop and then they
kind of changed the riders.
So there is a way to have a voice.
You're able to have an immediate boys and
I think that's important because there
used to be a time it had been a letter
writing campaign or something which is
very sluggish and ineffective.
The movie would have been in the theaters
by the time people knew about the
protests. I think that that as you point
out, that is a terrible thing to do.
Why would you do that?
There are,
and there really is a galling lack
of Asian representation in movies,
in pop culture in general.
You know,
you're starting to see more
of that but not enough.
They can't afford to
do that at this point.
And I'm so glad that people spoke out
and I hope that teaches them a lesson
cause I wanted to see ghost in the shell,
but I couldn't cause even though scarlet
Johannson is like one of my woman crush
Wednesdays,
I could not do it because you know what,
it's such a huge
opportunity that you missed.
And I think people need to understand,
they may ignore a protest,
but when they see the box office numbers
drop, there's no way to ignore that.
And Hollywood is driven by money.
So as the media,
so if you speak with your
dollars and you don't invest,
they will figure out a different
way to do things they always have.
Hmm.
I'm going to ask you one last question
and then we'll open it up and we've got
some mikes here.
If he wants to start lining up with the
questions and you're dying to ask her
camera, but, um, it's a, a little,
a bit more about, you know,
we opened up with who are you?
I want to also ask you, um,
a topic that's come up and out of our
Anarbor office. And it is a series.
First Time I discovered I was black and
that was a Googler who thought of the
series,
create and produce a 30 minute video
segment inspired by what he'd seen on CNN
of the same title. Okay. When was the
first time you realized you were black?
It was a wonderful day. I can
remember that much. Um, you know,
I think I was exposed early.
I would say maybe the content,
the context of color and race and that
maybe when I was about four or five,
because I grew up in a predominantly
Irish neighborhood and I didn't,
my mother really didn't have a choice.
You know,
there were children playing with the hair
and rubbing on the skin and I was like,
what are they doing? And they would ask
us, you know, why our dolls, where this,
cause my mother bought us black dolls
because she wanted to reinforce our beauty
ideal. So we had some beautiful black
dolls, like one look like Felicia Rashad.
They were so pretty. And the
fact that we had them, you know,
Austin cause questions from
the kids in the neighborhood.
So I believe as early as that, I figured
it out in the my mother, you know,
talk to us about it, you know,
talked about the differences,
talked about history to us in a way
that we can understand and consume.
So I felt luckier than some other children
when I went to school and they really
weren't aware of our history in that and
they seem to be more subject to being
like shamed for being different.
Whereas with me, I was like,
you're just mad because your hair does
it do this, you know? So, um, you know,
I had a different and much
more positive I, you know,
feeling about it then if I had come
in there and been surprised, you know,
you and I were talking earlier
today about the sports caster, who,
who said that,
you know,
he doesn't know what he is and race
doesn't matter anyway. And I mean,
I feel like this is a man that
he probably should not, you know,
at this point about 50 years old, he's,
if he's passed at least three mirrors,
he should, he should
know. But you know, I,
the fact that that's
still happening though,
that just tells you how
fraught with controversy,
the topic is identification
and I'm embracing your culture.
It's still something that is
not easy for anyone for sure.
But shouldn't you be able to hear the
voice that you had such a beautiful
narrative and growing up and hearing
that story and being able to project your
voice right and to read about likeminded
voices as well. Exactly. Right.
And I think that's extremely important.
You know,
in the black community and people
of color. I think there's a saying,
it's like you have to see it to be it,
you know,
seeing even President Barack
Obama ascend that way, you know,
kids my age probably didn't think that
that could happen just based on the way
that society is set up.
But there are generations of
children that for them that's a goal.
They don't even think twice about
it because they've seen it and it,
it's sad that we just need to see more
examples and then in people being free to
talk about them in, in various outlets
and in movies and TV and pop culture.
Absolutely.
You spark some ideas as well as to
how we can do that sponsorship and,
and others. Okay.
Wonderful. Well turn to um,
some live questions and pass it over.
Okay.
Thank you so much Carter. He'll come
in and speaking with us. Of course.
So we've heard a lot,
you know, for uh, women,
female executives of color come and
speak to us and share the experiences.
Some of them actually expressed that
they felt more discrimination as a woman
than as a person of color. So let's
get your experiences, you know,
does that align to your expectations and
your experiences and what you've seen,
the media industry or, or, or what,
yeah, what's the situation there?
No, for me personally, and again,
this is just for me personally,
I feel that blackness cannot be extracted
from my woman as I feel like they're
one thing.
Um,
black women in general are treated
differently than white women are treated.
And I don't have the statistics
with me at the moment,
but in just in terms of being in a
workplace and having internal advocates,
black women felt much less
supported than white women.
Now white women felt much less supported
than white men. So it's like they say,
you know, the old saying, it's like there
are levels to this. So I think that,
you know, when I come into
a room, people see a woman.
But I think first and foremost,
a lot of times they see a black woman.
I don't think I'm able to, you know,
I'm a woman now and no sort of like,
you know,
so I can only speak to mine.
But I think what I like it because
I think I find it empowering.
Like that's a double challenge that I'm
facing in society and for me to be able
to make it as far as I've made it be
able to sit here and address you all.
I mean, I think that that, I hope
that inspires other young black girls.
I hope that inspires people.
I don't want to make light of the
challenges that I face and say, oh no,
it's no problem.
Because I don't want other people who
are experiencing problems to think that
they, you know, are being singled
out. No, it's a problem usually.
But my hope is that by doing this
and by talking to more people,
it will be less of a problem until it's
not a problem at all. So that's the goal.
But that's an excellent question.
And I'm sure there are different people
that would answer it differently too.
There's,
there's this concept of allies I Google
because no matter how you identify,
right, you can have sponsors in the room
to make sure that your voice is heard.
And I think it's something that is work
in progress here and that we're also
trying to influence in the world. But, uh,
with the beautiful leaders, I mean, and I,
I love them that that's a priority because
I think sometimes we take for granted
that if you worked somewhere,
you'll get a mentor.
They'll just appear to you out of thin
air. No, people have to step up. Yeah.
And I think that that's great that
you're encouraging that. So that,
that's terrific.
Thank you.
Hi,
my name's Jonathan.
And first I just want to thank you
for taking the time to speak with us.
It's been a really powerful
message, uh, throughout your career.
You've had the opportunity to
work at a number of institutions,
large and small,
some that have gotten it right,
some that continued to get it wrong.
And you gave all those examples
earlier where it was almost like,
how could this happen?
How could you get to this point in your
creative process or have you in your
execution?
And no one asks the question and the
checks and balances oftentimes came from
the public. Uh, would love
to know, in your experience,
what are some of the hallmarks of
institutions that get it right?
And what are some of the checks and
balances they establish internally to make
sure that the product that they put out
is more reflective, is more diverse?
Well, that's a, that's a fantastic
question. And I'll say, to be fair,
obviously it's not just the
media industry. I mean, we
all saw that tone deaf. Um,
Kylie Jenner,
Pepsi ad where she solved black lives
matters issues with a carbonated beverage
and somebody bought space for that,
you know, and only until people said,
what are you doing? Did they
pull the commercial? I've
never would have aired it.
You know, it was like a Saturday
night live sketch waiting to happen.
Like you did Lauren Michaels work
for him. Beyonce is black, right?
Yeah. So I well that wax figure, have you
seen that? They have her looking. Okay.
But anyway, we'll talk
about that later. But um,
I would say in terms
of checks and balances,
I think it's important to have people
of different backgrounds with different
experiences in the room. Unfortunately,
especially in the United States,
I think we have a lot of segregation
at work and at home we have a lot of
segregation in terms of who we to.
So maybe some of these people didn't
have a friend that they could say, hey,
we're doing something at work and you
know, I, it's going to be pretty big.
I'd like to get your thoughts on it.
They may not have had that.
So if you don't have that in your friends
circle, you should have it at work.
And I think what you also need,
which is super important,
is you need to have people of color in
the leadership roles too because there
sometimes people in the room and
they're intimidated to speak.
Like when I got called in there for
that Hurricane Katrina conversation,
I did think they all seemingly have
made up their mind that it's okay to use
this term refugee. I might end up
getting in trouble and I might, you know,
I might jeopardize a promotion in the
future by being that girl that came in
here and told them what was what.
But my great grandmother marched with
Martin Luther King. I could not, you know,
and I'm not saying that like I'm
some martyr because guess what,
I would have gotten another job I'm sure,
but I couldn't do it cause
I couldn't be the one.
I actually had readers call me when they
would see things wrong in the newspaper.
How did you sit up there
and let that happen?
So I also had that responsibility to
and I had to tell them, you know guys,
I can't control everything but I did
take my responsibility seriously.
Some of it is not only just
having people in the room,
empowering them to speak and also having
them at different levels of the company,
not just in the creative and out front
fields but in behind the scenes so that
they can stop it before it.
Even as you mentioned,
get so far up in the creative process
that you're already casting for Kylie's,
you know police officer,
she's going to hand the Pepsi too.
They should never have. No, that's a
number of happened honestly. No problem.
You mentioned fragmentation and how people
have like a great ability to control
what they see in her to interact with.
Do you think the media
landscape is getting a lot
more fragmented these days in
terms of people being able to self select
more and more specific outlets and do
you think that's going to present like
a big problem for the types of issues
we're talking about?
Well, I think it already
presented a big problem.
I think it has a lot to do with our
election results to be honest. I mean,
and not to get super political,
but there's proof that people
reading erroneous information,
people reading kind of
race baiting or just plain,
I'm not factual information had
an effect on the way people voted,
had an effect on the way
people came out to vote.
And I think we do live in a time where
you could be in a bubble if you want to,
if you decide to wake up and use one
news source for everything and only go to
those things that agree with you.
Like I'll admitted my in my
little circle of Facebook friends.
Most of us agree when someone doesn't,
it's really jarring,
but that's actually not a great
thing because then you're kind of,
you're being reinforced and you
think what you're doing is right.
You don't have any educated dissenter.
I'm not talking about a troll,
I'm talking about somebody who really
knows what they're talking about.
We are seeing more consolidation of
news entities teaming up and working
together because of a lack of resources.
They almost have to work together. But I,
I do think that's what I'm kind of
afraid of is that people will become so
disenchanted with the way
that the traditional media
is that they will just say,
I'm not going to read that.
I'm just going to rely on this small blog
with like three people that don't have
enough people to do an investigative
bureau. And I'm going to do,
I'm going to go with whatever they say.
So I think it is a problem,
but we can head that off by bringing some
of those voices into the mainstream in
larger outlet.
Thank you. Thank you. You touched
on it on the issue with, uh,
the cost of journalism
and needing to be able to,
to sponsor and fund quality journalism.
Um,
but when we look at the
numbers and shifts, where in,
in terms of the minority will become the
majority at those ad dollars will need
to kind of be invested.
There was a question that came
in from one of the colleagues,
which was when you think of the
traditionally black publications, um,
their voice is really focused on,
on their audience with
this shift in demographics,
how do you see that?
Is that kind of evolution for those
publications to Ebony's jets in the world?
So that's a great question.
So
I can say from my personal experience
and what I observed and Wendy and Melissa
yell out if I'm incorrect,
they worked with me, um, at
avenue when I was there. Uh,
sometimes advertisers seem to believe
that they can get advertising in these
black publications investing less than
they would for a mainstream outlet.
Even if they see that the numbers
that they're getting are very similar.
And I think that's another systemic issue.
The fact that you think you
should pay less for the same.
So that is a problem and it's hard to
really get hardcore with them because then
they can take their dollars and invest
digitally with some of these outlets that
may not be as established, but it
doesn't cost as much to invest that way.
But again, journalism does cost
money. Good journalism does.
You can't do investigations.
You can't be thorough. Sure.
You can write a lot of opinion pieces
that are based in existing fact,
but you can't do any deep digging
if you don't have money. So that,
that is an important thing.
And in one that I think
that the technology industry
could assist with if they
could fund certain initiatives,
if they could help, um,
maybe invest in investigative arms or
invest in certain investigations period.
I think that that would
be helpful. Um, it's,
it's a very difficult question because
one would think that the shift in
demographics would mean a shift in budget,
but it hasn't.
And a lot of people point
to the fact that yes,
there are niche black publications.
But you know,
I grew up reading all of the different
magazines too. I even had a situation,
this was very recent where I went
to a car dealership, spoiler alert,
I did not buy the car cause I did not
like this guy's attitude. He said to me,
I told him where I worked
at the time it was ebony.
He came up with this wonderful anecdote,
you know, trying to relate to me.
He was like, you know what? You're going
to think this is funny. And I was like,
oh my God,
I know I'm not going to.
He said to me that he loved
will Smith when he was a kid.
He would by will Smith on anything.
Didn't matter what it was.
He saw an avenue magazine with will Smith
on. He goes, so here I am, this kid.
I get up there and an Ebony magazine and
I'll be like, and the punchline is what?
And I was like,
every day that I buy a magazine,
these are not black magazines and no one,
the cashier has never stopped me. I, I'm,
I don't get the story.
You know,
why don't we just go back
to the dealership and then
I ended up buying a totally
different car.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like there's still this stigma and
thought that it'd be weird for a person
that's not black to buy this magazine.
But it's not weird for me
to buy a magazine that isn't
black owned and doesn't
have a black person on the cover. So,
and this happened last year, so it's not,
you know, some ancient tale I'm telling
and that says a lot about that situation.
Sound unfortunately it was for him
and it's failed to learn something.
You won't tell that story again. But hi.
Hi, my name is Latoya. I work on
a team called the news lab and um,
we are all about working with journalists
technologies to help build the future
of media. Um, I lead a piece of work on
the team call inclusive storytelling.
How do we elevate the voices that we
don't traditionally here in media?
I'm just going to point out one thing.
You mentioned that you need
sponsorships in dollars.
That's exactly what our tastes great.
Trying to, you know, increase. Uh,
we support the IDA B Wells
Society for instance,
which is about training journalists of
colors to be investigative journalist.
I wanted to ask you your thoughts on
what more technology companies can do.
If you think about,
you made the point about Pepsi and
people of Color not having a seat at the
table and not being in positions
of power to say something.
When we think about newsrooms, I think
we've seen the numbers, the leadership,
I think it's 86% of editorial
directors, so on or white men. Right?
How do you change that? What does
it take to shake up the newsrooms?
Is it a matter of just hiring more people,
going to find them?
What's the role of technology company can
play and really inspiring that change?
It's something we think about. We don't
have the answers, but it seems to,
that change comes down to getting
more people with a seat at the table,
but how do we make that happen?
Well,
you know I I really liked
and was encouraged by what
Google is doing with Howard
University by creating this space where
people of the university and students
are interacting directly
with Google employees, seeing
what their future can be,
seeing what the potential is.
Something to that effect in the area
of journalism I think would be very
impactful. I do think like what
you mentioned, the Ida B wells,
that sounds amazing.
I also noted that Google is going to be
a partner in evaluating the number of
minorities in journalism for next year,
which is great.
Having that transparency is extremely
important because how can we fix the
problem if we don't even
know the full scope of it?
Maybe you using technology
tools to create, um,
job bank databases or
helping create programs or
fellowships that pay a stipend.
As I mentioned,
the problem about news entities not
paying or paying below standard,
maybe in some way trying to help boost
that amount of pay so that people can
afford to enter the industry.
And then training.
So in Abj offers amazing training for
managers and people want to go into the
management track supporting those efforts
so that you don't just have people who
are the writers and they get on CNN
and yeah, everybody knows them by name,
but they don't necessarily have as
much power behind the scenes as these
producers and these other people who are
telling them where to go and what to do
and what to focus on.
So I think that what you mentioned is
a great start and just continuing to do
that and also making it easier
to find people are candidates.
It would be important. I think, um,
technology is very helpful in that it
connects people that might not otherwise
be connected.
But what I find that it does a lot of
times is it just makes it easier to
connect with those you already know.
And I would love to see some
technologies that push you beyond that.
One of my mentors and former managers,
Jane Huert that worked at the Tribune
Redeye what I love about her is that she
would go out of her way to
go find people of color,
people representing different areas
of the gender spectrum. She did this,
you know, with a conscious
thought, this is what I'm doing.
And not in a way of this
is a token higher, but this
is a super talented person.
I'm going to work with this person.
I'm gonna make sure that they feel
welcome to make sure that their voices are
heard. She will ask you, what do
you think about this? You know,
in a way that doesn't make it feel
like you're being pigeon holed.
And I think it's,
it's also that the manager mindset of
not bringing someone in so you can just
take a staff picture and look
like you're doing something,
but really making them part of the
process. And she did that really well.
So I bring her up as an example of what
I would love to see more managers do and
I'll be at nab and get to it. Okay. I'm
sure you will. New Orleans. All right.
So there's this photo on this screen
that I have to ask. What's the story?
I just liked the way I look
at it. No one's going to
fail. So I went on the real,
uh, I think it was wet in the, the
end of last year. Yeah. December, uh,
to talk about,
which is another important thing and
something that companies can support.
It's like the root does their own
version of this. A lot of entities do.
The power 100,
uh,
for Ebony was a way to highlight
people that are doing great things,
not just entertainment and
celebrity that you see every day,
but people in technology,
people in nonprofit,
people in the business
world and initiatives like
that are important because
again,
it's that see it to be it mentality.
So I was really happy to go on
there and the ladies were lovely.
They were very kind, you know, I didn't
get to drink whatever was in that mug.
I'm not sure what it is to
this day. But yeah, it was,
it was a great and empowering
experience. So I, I think we just,
we need more initiatives like that.
There are many people of color across
the globe doing terrific things.
It saddens me that sometimes those
people don't get the attention that they
deserve. And I think that if we can work
on our media coverage work on our media
newsrooms,
we will see more of that.
And in the problem will
not vanish overnight,
but we will make a lot more progress.
We are strong believers.
Our CEO has even said it,
a mix of diverse perspective and ideas
and backgrounds will only lead to better
products and better experiences.
Right. And I, I'm hopeful.
Um,
I guess as a
final question,
it would be what are you most excited
about for the next couple of years?
What I'm most excited about is two folds.
I'm excited by people of color deciding
that they will invest and create media
outlets,
show TV shows that they were showcased,
their talents and that they're doing
that and that they're getting a reception
for that. They're not waiting
around, they're not begging people,
please write me in or please cast me.
They're taking matters
into their own hands.
I think we're seeing a wave of content
creators of color that are making a big
splash.
It's not a niche thing.
It's not something that just a
handful of people are seeing.
You see that with Easter Ray. Um,
you see that with Donald Glover.
These are not people that
are just trying to be stars.
They're trying to make
opportunities for other people.
And I think that that's great. Jordan
Peele as well. Um, the other thing I,
I'm a very excited about and some people
in the industry might disagree with me
on this is the audience power.
I love that the audience can get you
right together really fast. You know,
I, I used to, when I was in the newsroom,
I know people used to hate
when the phone would ring.
They'd hate emails from the public.
I love them because that's
how I can do a better job.
How can I do a better job if I
have no idea what the reception is?
There were some people who live in this
little ivory tower and they think that
the public doesn't have the savvy
to comment on what they're doing,
but you're doing it for them.
So why can't they have a two
way conversation with you?
I love the fact that people
get dragged on Twitter.
Sometimes it's funnier than others. I
think it's appropriate though. It's,
you're putting something out there.
You can't dictate to me what I'm going to,
to engage in or what I'm going
to like or hate. And I love that.
So I think we're seeing power
to the people. So to speak,
and also power to the creators.
And that I think is exhilarating and
I'm excited to watch where that goes.
It's fantastic.
But you've been an inspiring and powerful
and beautiful voice are so lucky to
have had the opportunity to
have a conversation with you.
It's an honor to be here to see another
friend later at the conference. Yes,
thank you. All right,
wonderful. Thank you so much.
Sorry.